[Music]
so if you are interested in justice for
all the type of politics we have cannot
deliver that and the type of politics
that we have which is sectional politics
segregating people off and pursuing
particular interests liberal
emancipatory politics do not deliver and
if you're interested in the rise of
populism and the rise of the West it's
largely a pushback against social and
economic liberalism that fragments
people and doesn't deliver for the
bottom half and increasingly you'll soon
be the bottom 60% of society so if
you're interested in general
emancipation we need different forms and
different ways to argue against
discrimination so you basically want
socialism
I want a form of collective care for
everybody and I think there's then
there's legitimate difference between
how we achieve that so what I wanted to
suggest to you is the way we've been
trying to advance black people gay
people women bla bla bla is
fundamentally wrong and cannot deliver
on that general good and part of what I
think evinces this is if you look at the
current kind of war within feminism
between what one might call sex and
gender and and the transsexual count
because the type of capitalism or the
type of extreme liberalism that I think
we need to oppose is the type that
essentially individualizes us and strips
us of our difference to such an extent
that we can't cater for that difference
and make that difference equal with
other differences so in gender women are
looking at the erasure of their own
spaces are looking at the erasure of the
very idea of distinction the very idea
of women are essentially being removed
by transsexual type arguments so you're
getting an account that wants to take
the whole of women out of the equation
so you can't even have with feminism
because there's no such thing as women
because there's no sir because
everything is gender and everything is
flux
that's why I want to argue for
essentialism and I think that what we
need to recover before you argue for it
will you explain what it is okay
essentialism would be something like
squaring with the reality that men and
women exist as distinct biological
social cultural forms and they really
are different and the project of social
justice which I believe in is about how
those people don't pay a penalty for the
differences they have that's the new
project which will require in my view a
different type of feminism than the one
we currently have are just finished two
more minutes
one more minute because what we have
seen if we really care about justice the
most oppressed groups in the UK are
white working-class males they are the
people who pay the highest penalty there
are the people you have a brain migrant
women who know actually it's not
anecdotal positions but actually on the
bit on all the evidence that's been
presented white Mercat working class
males pay the highest penalty and here's
the two indicators that determine you
the place of your birth and the level of
your mother's education out-compete
every other indicator for what will
happen to you that that's clap we need a
separate session on essentialism and
class and whatever and I for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you